bonjour bassin rebonjour alors quelques
petits débordements
effectivement quelques petits
débordements suite à cette manifestation
des gilets jaunes qui avaient débuté il
ya quelques heures c'était un 17e
arrondissement là nous sommes dans le
18e arrondissement pas très loin de
pigalle où le calme est revenu les
forces de l'ordre ont été débordés
dépassés plusieurs dispersion ont eu
lieu des mondes et les bombes
lacrymogènes ont été même lancé sur
certains manifestants je suis avec
jérôme rodriguez un dg des jaunes
bonjour jérôme expliquez-nous un petit
peu ce qui s'est passé pourquoi s'est
dispersé comme ça bah écoutes je pense
que la la la la préfecture et est en
panique et aujourd'hui nous empêchent
d'avancer à notre guise de pipita
l'heure on est complètement menacé sur
la marche aujourd'hui tu as des gens qui
sont déterminés je pense pas qu'il ya un
réel climat de violence au sein de la
manifestation
sauf que le fait d'être cloîtré comme ça
au milieu des policiers at ease si tu
veux l'énervement et abandonner les mecs
pète un câble et et finissent par trans
transpercé la nasse sap a été bien
méchant je veux dire ça court et un peu
à droite à gauche et ça éviterait de
rentrer dans l'ordre mais voilà que que
la police et la préfecture nous laisse
avancer quoi on demande simplement
d'avancé c'est très important pouvant
temps que gilles et jouer comme tous les
autres jeunes d'être présent pour ce 1er
mai les mêmes revendications
écoute on reste sur notre base de
revendications injustice sociale justice
fiscale et bien sûr démocratie directe
et participative à savoir que le 1er mai
c'est quand même la fête des
travailleurs et que faut rappeler à ce
qu'ils ont toujours pas compris que
l'ensemble des légendes sont des
travailleurs aujourd'hui invisible qui
gagne peu et qui ont du mal à boucler
les fins de mois
donc il était légitime qu'on puisse être
aujourd'hui dans cette manifestation est
de pouvoir être visible montré que les
gilets jaunes sont des travailleurs et
de rejoindre cette cette belle fête du
travail avec l'ensemble des
manifestations un peu partout en france
donc l'heure de rendez vous donné place
de la république
exactement là on va vers la place de la
république après il ya aussi un autre
rassemblement place vauban avec des
marcheurs qui sont venus de montpellier
qui ont fait 700 km pour depuis le 19
mars pour arriver jusque jusque sur
paris avec les revendications et pas mal
d'actions à venir
donc voilà on est sur le terrain on est
bien présent et voilà l'important c'est
de se faire entendre le plus
pacifiquement possible est de pouvoir
arriver au bout de nos revendications et
et d'être entendu par un gouvernement
aujourd'hui sourd aux attentes des
français et qu'ils profitent d'une
situation de crise sanitaire pour encore
plus mettre en souffrance ne
les la liberté de l'ensemble des
français merci beaucoup j'aime brega
alors vous l'aurez compris la
manifestation on suit toujours son cours
elle a commencé il ya quelques heures
dans le xviie lala marché suit son cours
direction place de la république le
calme est revenu mais le cortège est
toujours encerclée par un important
dispositif de sécurité crs jardin ou
encore police on continue cette marche
direction place de la république pour
cette manifestation du 1er mai